bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa dj e come solito gen siamo
in un piede mi sono intrippato troppo
oggi siamo in un video ragazzi anche se
domenica non esce più
lo faccio uscire domani perché volevo
dirvi che stasera alle alle 6 c'è prati
mentre casi la live in diretta che
quella che avevo già organizzata da una
settimana è faccio questo video soltanto
per ricordarlo perché molti magari
dicono che fa affari dove video agli
occhi non è mica faccio la live
ok quindi se volete partecipare ragazzi
avete ancora tempo di farlo il vi lascio
il link nella descrizione dei giochi che
faccio stasera sono free to play quindi
potete scaricarli gratis
e stasera ci francesi gli faccio i culi
va beh niente ragazzi soltanto questo
quindi ricordatevi alle 6 ci sono
preparatevi scaricatevi dei giochi
perché poi sono entrate ultimi non so se
ce la fate quindi ragazzi spero che
siate pronti come al solito se volete
rimanere aggiornati volate anche alla
pagina di facebook è vista in
descrizione se ne vorresti discreti ci
vediamo il prossimo video alle sei bella
ragazzi